[Music]
hi everyone I'm Michael mikela get
Michael M for the long now foundation
we're so glad you're here this is going
to be a fantastic talk it's it's
something that's near and dear to our
hearts here as you can tell we do like
books and we like both the science and
the fiction and to realize they should
actually be kind of classified as the
same thing well we're gonna get into
that tonight so Anna Lee as you may know
was a founding editor of
io9.com she's currently the editor at
large at ARS technica she's the author
of autonomous and want to give a shout
out to borderlands books are great local
sci-fi and other awesome genre bookstore
in the back Thank You Jude and team we
love it when we've got and so they've
got both Anneliese novel and her
nonfiction which you can buy tonight
she's going to hang out and sign it
afterwards she's also going to answer
more of your questions because we won't
be able to answer all of them I'm sure
during the talk so we hope you'll stick
around we'll be we'll be here afterwards
and she will be signing books afterwards
and we'll be selling more books
afterwards as well so here we have an
author a novelist a journalist a thinker
who has hands-on experience in both the
fantastic and the concrete in the
imagining and the documenting and she's
gonna explain to us how it all fits
together also the big round of applause
for Hannah Lee Nuits
[Applause]
thanks so much and thanks Michael for
inviting me to be part of this series
and I just I love the interval and if I
ever have a spaceship
I want the industrial design inside of
it to look like this so that's my plan
and part of the reason why I wanted to
have these space robots here I'm not
going to talk a lot about space robots
may be sort of peripherally but I was as
a kid inspired a lot by Voyager and of
course one of my first grown-up
science-fiction films
star Voyager who had become a sentient
being who went by V jure and when I was
7 years old the reveal at the end when
it was Voyager I was like so deep so
that so that's been been with me since I
was a kid both the real spacecraft and
the science fictional version of it who
came to life so as Michael said I am a
science journalist and I also write
science fiction which means I'm in this
kind of space in the middle of fiction
and nonfiction and a lot of my
nonfiction tends to have speculation in
it speculative moments and my science
fiction is very much grounded in science
and I have had a lot of fun interviewing
scientists and getting them to think
about some of the the issues in my book
and then just stealing their ideas and
putting them into fiction and and my
project really throughout my adult life
as I've been working in this kind of
space is to carve out a spot where you
know science fiction can kind of be the
cultural wing of the scientific project
and I'm going to talk a lot about how
that might work tonight and it's
definitely not an injunction I'm not
saying like okay scientists you have to
make room for me now but it's just a
kind of a way of thinking about where
does science fiction and where does
fiction fit into the scientific project
because the scientific project of course
goes way beyond the borders of the
laboratory as we know so I started my
career as an academic at UC Berkeley and
I wrote my dissertation on him yeah
Berkeley
and I wrote my dissertation on how in
part on how images of science and
technology in pop culture affect
people's perception of politics and then
I escaped from academia and started
creating images of science and
technology and pop culture so that was
an odd journey and so I when I left the
ivory tower I spent many years writing
about technology and writing about the
social impact of technology I had a
column that ran in newspapers for a long
time called text light a ssin which some
of you might remember if you were
reading newspapers in the 90s or the
early noughties like one person is like
paper it was online - okay it was legit
and and then I slowly shifted into
thinking about science and I was lucky
enough to be able to found a blog called
io9 along with Charlie Jane Anders who's
sitting right here and which was part of
a larger company that was at the time
known as Gawker Media and is now called
Gizmodo Media and that's a long story
that we won't go into but that was my
first chance to really have a space
where people who were the contributors
and the staffers were writing about both
science fiction and science and we had
very we they still have io9 is still
going very serious cultural analysis of
where science fiction kind of fits into
our world but also really paying
attention to scientific discoveries and
technological innovations and doing very
high quality science journalism as well
and it was definitely in imitation of
the old Omni magazine which also used to
do that and which was a huge influence
on me and all right-thinking people and
and I I wanted to continue that
tradition of blending the two and
bringing speculation and storytelling
into the scientific project and so while
I was at i/o nine Wow I have not been
advancing my slides I'm so sorry there's
the opening slide
so while I was at io9 I wrote a
nonfiction book called scatter adapt and
remember which is about mass extinction
which is something that we're actually
facing now a lot of environmental
scientists believe that were kind of in
the early stages of a mass extinction
and my book was I don't want to say it
was optimistic but of course it was
about how we might survive a mass
extinction as a species which many
people considered to be so outrageously
utopian that they would just threw the
book down and discussed so we'll we'll
talk a little bit about that later I
want to talk a little bit about utopian
and dystopian visions and how they fit
into the scientific project I didn't
actually think it was wildly utopian I
actually thought it was pretty dystopian
cuz I was saying well we're surviving
but we'll we'll be doing it by living in
caves and eating bugs not that there's
anything to get bad about eating bugs I
love bugs they seem tasty so and so
since this since that time since I
worked at io9 for almost eight years and
worked on this book I've become a
freelancer I've turned to writing my
first science fiction novel which I will
do a little reading from later just I
have a few snippets that I'll read to
you from and talk about that but this
novel autonomous grew out of a lot of
the work that I was doing as a science
journalist in fact as I said a lot of it
was just stolen straight from science
stories that I'd been writing partly
about the development of machine
learning but also about the development
of pharmaceuticals and there's two main
characters in the novel who you'll meet
not in real life but every when I wish
in real life that would be really
interesting but one of the characters is
a pharmaceutical pirate she's a former
synthetic biologist who's been working
on gene therapies in in academia but she
realizes that all of her work is tied up
in patents and corporate interests and
so in order to bring medicine to people
she feels need need it poor people she
goes rogue and starts reverse
engineering expensive drugs and selling
them very cheaply or giving them away
for free so she kind of gets in trouble
as you do when you're stealing drugs
from pharmaceutical companies and so
corporation sends a robot after her a
robot and a human companion to track her
down and so the novel kind of goes back
and forth between their perspectives
that of this pirate who doesn't respect
intellectual property laws and a robot
who is property but who's also a
conscious human equivalent being so that
was that just came out and it got
nominated for a Nebula so that was I was
pretty sick so before I talk about
because I want it I want to kind of
delve into the process of what it means
to try to write science fiction that's
informed by real science but before that
I just want to define some terms here
because I think that science fiction can
mean a lot of things fiction can mean a
lot of things so when I talk about
science fiction and here we have Spock
looking at a tricorder he has that sort
of cute puzzled expression that he
always has so yes so you know there's
this common belief among readers and I
think some science fiction writers that
science fiction succeeds when it
predicts the future and you always see
articles in places like Gizmodo or
popular science that are all about like
which science fiction got it right and
which ones got it wrong you know which
ones you know actually predicted that we
would have cellphones or revenge porn or
whatever and which didn't and I think
that like like a lot of science fiction
writers like Cory Doctorow and William
Gibson I don't believe that we're
wizards that who can predict the future
like if I could do that that would be
awesome but that is not within my power
and I science fiction is generally about
the present it's about exploring the
ways that science fits into our culture
and our society and projecting it into a
speculative realm so that speculative
realm might be the future it might be an
alternative history it might be a
fantasy world but that's really when I
approach science fiction I'm approaching
it not as a predictive tool but as a
tool for world building and I'll talk a
little bit more about world building as
I go along but basically by world
building I just mean
way of thinking about science or
technology in the context of the full
world and there's some science fiction
writers for example Kim Stanley Robinson
who Michael mentioned was here who
really take that quite seriously and try
to build an entire world for you in
their work which I love the novel 23:12
which is one of my favorite Kim Stanley
Robinson novels really is an effort to
build an entire civilization for you to
understand the context for all of the
scientific developments and
technological developments and how they
are embedded in political practices and
social practices and then there's other
writers who think about that same
question but from a very personal angle
like philip k dick is a great example of
that in k Jemison who's broken earth
trilogy just like rocked the world
recently both of them explore how
technology impacts people's personal
lives their psychology how it mutates
our psychology and so that's another
exercise in world-building so world
building doesn't have to just mean that
I go full Ursula Gwyn and like build a
planet and tell you about every single
political faction on the planet it can
also mean just taking a character and
thinking about how does this technology
change her relationship with someone or
her relationship with herself so that's
kind of my my view of it and you know I
think there's a huge temptation now
especially to really focus on the
predictive aspects of science fiction
because we're at a point historically
where it just seems like almost anything
that we could imagine in sci-fi could
come true and there's that kind of urge
to say well let's read science fiction
to get ideas for things to build because
it's it's all possible we have such
advanced technology we have advanced
fabrication techniques we're making
strides in a lot of areas of scientific
discovery so why not just think of
science fiction as kind of a testbed and
I was thinking about this especially the
other day because Elon Musk he was being
kind of musky on Twitter and here's
I've seen this he tweeted hey you guys
I'm gonna build a candy factory and it's
gonna be awesome and it was funny and
like a million people responded and one
person responded and said come on
Ilan we don't want a candy factory we
want you to make west world real and
Elon Musk was like yeah or something
like he said something funny in response
and to me that's a perfect example of
people kind of using science fiction in
the wrong way I'm sure this person was
joking I don't think that he really
wanted West world to be real I hope but
you know the point of West world is not
to watch it and be like dude I want like
a sex robot or like a cowboy robot who I
can murder over and over again and like
implant with like several layers of PTSD
until he has like no identity other than
his fear of death you know the point
West world is very much about thinking
about that technology of human
equivalent a AI in a robotic body
embedded in a political structure
embedded in a corporate structure
embedded in a social structure and how
that plays out because of course the
message of West world is not build these
robots it's like no no no no don't build
these robots like this if you build
robots and you place them in this
context you're creating slaves who are
horrific ly abused and that's not what
we want to do as people who are
interested in advancing the scientific
project so now I want to switch gears
and talk a little bit about how I go
about building worlds as a fiction
writer when I set out to write
autonomous I spent a lot of time looking
at this map which is from it's actually
two maps I'm sorry it's from a paper
that came out in 2013 in the Proceedings
and out the Proceedings of the National
Academy of Sciences commonly referred to
as penis so in my head I was like penis
they all think that's funny over there
too they don't mind that joke
but this is a this is from a paper about
the impact of climate change on the
dick you can see one is showing and it's
showing shipping routes so one on the
left you can see ship current shipping
routes up to 2015 and then projected
shipping routes from 2040 to 2050 nine
one of my character is the pirate Jack
of course she has a pirate ship because
she's a pirate and it's as bad a
submarine that she uses to kind of
crisscross the Arctic to get from the
manufacturing point for her drugs to a
distribution point and so partly this
was just I needed to think about how
would she do it you know what would it
look like to cross the Arctic sea at a
time when most of the ice has melted and
that's exactly the point here is that
once that ice melts you're gonna see a
lot more shipping lanes taking up space
and of course leaving you know debris
behind and polluting and all kinds of
other stuff disturbing
you know wildlife habitats but also the
thing that's interesting I'd like to
start with maps when I'm doing world
building because this map actually poses
a lot of questions like for one thing it
poses the question of like what's
happening with climate change that's
really obvious but then it's saying not
just what's gonna happen to the
environment but what will happen it
happened to the economy because this is
about shipping lanes it's about cargo so
how will that impact the economy it's
also about politics because which
nations will have access to it as a big
question but also for me as I was
thinking about Jack in her submarine
like zooming along in the in the humm
Arctic sea I was like how does she get
internet and because she's constantly
online she's doing a bunch of stuff and
I was like okay I have to come up with
that I have to build my world to make
that happen and so I came up with this
idea which may be total crap but this is
what I came up with that there are motes
that serve as internet relay nodes this
is the future kids it's 125 years in the
future so there's these tiny tiny little
relays that are dusted into the air by
airplanes and if you're rich enough your
town gets a nice dusting of Internet
relay points and they're just in the air
and if you're not you know your
community has a really shitty internet
access
but because of the fact that the Arctic
is like a major shipping route it's cut
it's being dusted regularly with these
modes and so suddenly I had a way to
have her have internet access that made
sense and also embedded in this economy
where certain places have access and
certain people don't so I'm going to
read you a short piece from the novel
where I introduced Jack and just
describe basically it's a sneaky way of
introducing you to the tech in the world
you're supposed to be just you know
meeting the character and it's like
there's action kind of but actually it's
just me being like dude let me tell you
about all the tech so she's been she's
been online so this is why it starts
with her taking goggles off because
she's reading the internet using kind of
squishy goggles Jack Chen unstuck the
goggles from her face and squeezed the
deactivated lenses into the front pocket
of her coveralls she'd been working in
the sun's glare for so long that pale
rings circled her dark brown eyes it was
a farmer's tan like the one on her
father's face after a long day wearing
goggles in the canola fields watching
tiny yellow flowers emit streams of
environmental data probably jack
reflected he was the same farmer's tan
that had afflicted every Chen for
generations it went back to the days
when her great great grandparents came
across the Pacific from Shenzhen and
brought an agricultural franchise in the
prairies outside Saskatoon no matter how
far she was from home some things did
not change but some things did Jack sat
cross-legged in the middle of the Arctic
sea balanced on the gently curving
uncanny invisibility of her submarines
halt from a few hundred kilometers above
the surface where satellites roamed the
subs negative refractive index would
bend light until Jack seemed to float in
Congress Lee atop the waves spread next
to her in the bright water was an
undulating sheet of non reflective solar
panels Jack made a crumpling gesture
with her hand and the solar array swarm
back into its dock disappearing beneath
a panel in the hall
the subs batteries were charged her
network traffic was hidden in a blur of
legitimate data and she had a hold full
of drugs it was time to dive jack is so
badass um so anyway what you can see in
that scene like I said it's a bit of a
kind of sneak info dump because it's
basically me saying like let me
introduce you to the tech in this world
and part of it is that they have
fantastic sustainable technology she's
got these great solar panels that are
basically like crumbly paper that she
can store all mashed up inside her hole
all of the energy that we see people
using in the novel is sustainable energy
it's alternative energy people are
building with sustainable materials and
it's in partly in response to stuff like
this because they're living in a world
where there's no more Arctic ice we've
really been seeing the results of
climate change and so in many ways and
people reading the novel have said to me
that they're a bit surprised at how
utopian it is because there's all of
this amazing green technology and cities
that are you know thriving by having
skyscraper farms and collecting light
you know for energy but at the same time
it's not a perfect world because I
really wanted to make it as realistic as
possible and so of course one of the big
tools in your toolbox as a fiction
writer is you get to have characters and
characters are a big part of world
building because of course as you're
thinking about how technology affects
the world it kind of comes down to how
does it affect people you know it's not
I think there's this misnomer this is
paladin the robot this is actually not
paladin this is briea Rios from
Appleseed how many people know what
Appleseed is yeah it's a really great
anime you should check it out
briea rios is a super sexy cyborg and i
kind of modeled the character of paladin
who's the robot in my novel after this
anime bought but you know when we're
when we're thinking
characters and we're thinking about how
they interact with tech and science I
find that it's really important to keep
in mind that technology doesn't change
the world it's about how people receive
technology and deploy technology person
is Oh a person or a person like creature
always has to be the subject of any
sentence that is about what technology
is doing right it's not like suddenly
there's robots and robots change things
it's it's about how do people use those
robots and so I'm gonna redo a little
bit from the introduction to paladin and
give you a sense of what I mean by that
about how people are using this
technology and so this is a scene where
we first are kind of meeting paladin
paladin is like I said a big giant bot
he has giant shields that look like
wings because I just couldn't help but
make him super badass he has like lasers
and [ __ ] he's got all the stuff all the
sexy stuff and paladin is about to go be
deployed on this mission to chase down
Jack and has just met his human partner
whose name is Elias and so he and Elias
are doing a training exercise and Elias
says where are you from paladin I
suppose I am from the kaabah robotics
Factory in Cape Town
he vocalized no no no Elias shook his
head violently then wrapped his knuckles
on paladin's lower back I mean where are
you from originally where is your brain
from under its layers of abdominal
shielding paladin's bio brain floated in
a thick mixture of shock gel and
cerebrospinal fluid there was a fat
interface wire between it and the
physical substrate of his mind the brain
took care of his facial recognition
functions assigning each person he met a
unique identifier based on the edges and
shadows of their expressions but its
file system was largely incompatible
with his own he used it mostly like a
graphics processor he certainly had no
idea where it was
beyond the fact that a dead human
working for the Federation military had
donated it
Elias spoke again isn't it important to
you to know who you really are
why you feel what you do none of
paladins emotions or ethics were
processed in his human brain but then
Elias looked right into the sensor array
mounted on palette and space his eyes
dark and attentive suddenly Paladin
didn't really want to explain his file
system architecture anymore happens to
me all the time I don't know where my
brain is from he replied simply I can't
access its memories and so then they
have a bit more of a conversation where
Elias is like they should let you
remember because Elias has probably seen
a lot of movies like Robocop where the
brain matters and Paladin is like I
don't know what I don't know what to say
and then paladin is and then they're
deployed they get a message saying that
they're going to be deployed and paladin
is thinking about going on the mission
though the mission was fairly small
scale and routine it held a special
significance for paladin because it
meant he'd crossed over from development
to deployment today marked the first day
of his indenture to the African
Federation international law mandated
that his service could last no more than
10 years a period deemed more than
enough time to make the Federation's
investment in creating a new life form
worthwhile though he was just beginning
his term of indenture paladin had heard
enough around the factory to know that
the federation interpreted the law
fairly liberally he might be waiting to
receive his autonomy key for 20 years
more likely he would die before ever
getting it but he wanted to survive that
urge was part of his programming it was
what defined him as human equivalent and
therefore deserving autonomy the bot had
no choice but to fight for his life
still too paladin it didn't feel like a
lack of choice it felt like hope so
I know paladin he he has she has a rough
time I actually switched pronouns back
and forth for paladin because one of the
things that happens in the middle of the
book and this is not really a spoiler is
that paladin starts to you it starts to
paladin experiments with using a female
pronoun for a lot of different reasons
probably having to do with that sexy
look that Elias gave her earlier but one
of the things there were a few things
that I wanted to call out in that scene
and talk about in relation to how a
character can help you think about
technology in a social context one is
that you see Elias completely
misunderstanding how the robot's mind
works right this is a user who's
approaching this device and thinks that
that the seed of its of its
consciousness is in the brain because
humans have brains and our brains or the
seat of our consciousness so he's
completely misunderstood that he's
misunderstood paladin's relationship
with paladins brain and in many ways
throughout the novel
Elias is misunderstanding of Paladin
kind of shaped the way paladin feels
about herself the way he moves through
the world because Elias also assumes
that because paladin is a big bulky
armored creature that paladin must be
male but paladin is a robot and robots
don't have gender so paladin's like what
do you wait why do you think I'm male
and why do you even care and why does it
matter to humans what is this whole
gender thing so paladin is like super
confused by gender and we also get this
look inside paladins consciousness and
how paladin responds to his programming
and again that's something that when we
think about robots
you know we're humans right so we think
about like how do we program them to do
things but not how would subjectively
feel to have those programs running and
I wanted to point out that you know when
we think about making a creature who is
alive or artificially alive oftentimes
scientists and technologists will say
well the thing that defines a life-form
is that they fight to survive and so
therefore we'll program in our strong AI
fight to survive and that is something
that paladin has no choice about right
it's programmed in
just the way it's programmed into us
that we fight for our lives and we fight
to survive but as humans just like
Paladin we don't think about that as
programming we don't think like oh the
fact that I have no choice but to fight
for my life means that I've been
programmed and I have no choices we feel
like a sense of hope because of that we
feel like that fighting for that
survival is is a hopeful thing and so I
wanted to remind readers that you know
the way that we think about our
technology isn't always the way that
other people will think about it
especially the technology itself if it
ever becomes sentient which is a big
debate but I really I think it's
important to think about especially how
people mistake
the way technology functions and that's
like I said a big part of the book so I
wanted to end by talking a little bit
about in my talk about the book by just
saying that one of the big focuses I've
had in my work has been trying to get
out of the idea that there's such a
thing as a dystopia or a utopia because
of the fact that my book has slavery in
it the robots are indentured until
they're ten and as a result of that
lawyer clever corporate lawyers have
figured out a way to make humans
indentured as well because of course
robots are human equivalent so if robots
are human equivalent why not have some
human slavery - that's great but it's
indenture it's freely entered into it's
not really like slavery it's actually
kind of nice right because somebody pays
for your meals you get to have a house
so you can see why people would love
that idea so so that's very dystopian
the idea of reinventing slavery in the
in the 21st century but at the same time
the book is full of this incredible
green technology sustainable technology
people are dealing really well with
trying to conserve and and preserve the
environment so it's a little dystopia
it's a little utopia
it's just topia and I think as you know
as we think about science in the context
of stories and in the context of these
kinds of world building maps it's
important to remember that as we move
into the future
we're
really heading toward a world where
things tend toward getting better and
better and better by some person's
definition of better and better or
really worse and worse we're always in
these middle phases where some things
are getting better for some people some
things are getting worse for some people
the reality is that even if we you know
achieve some kind of goal like say
universal health care for all there's
gonna be another problem that comes up
so we're never gonna reach a point where
like you know we're become light-filled
beings and beam out of existence like in
Star Trek there's always going to be
these problems that come up and I think
science sometimes makes the mistake
those of us working in science or
technology of thinking but it's getting
better and better and better and better
and like everybody's just gonna be fine
it's like nope there's always going to
be new problems and we need to think
about what those problems are gonna be
brand-new awesome problems and this is
I'm just gonna tell you briefly about my
next project which kind of grows out of
these concerns about the new problems
and the old problems kind of haunting
the new problems I'm working on a
nonfiction book about ancient abandoned
cities or lost cities although they're
not really lost and thinking about
cities like Angkor that is a lidar image
of Angkor that was taken quite recently
that reveals that in fact Angkor the
city not the kind of walled area of
Angkor Thom and Angkor Wat which you can
see Angkor Thom is at the top it's that
big kind of rectangle and then at the
bottom you can see Angkor Wat all of the
rest of this stuff is a city grid that's
been obscured by jungle it's been
obscured by time but the lidar can pick
up you know minut like centimeter level
shifts in the in the in the height of
the ground and it's able to recreate
that city grid which has stood the test
of time over a thousand years and what
that means is now we know that Angkor in
fact was the biggest city in the world
about a thousand years ago there were a
million people living there and we can
see where they lived and how they walked
to work and where they got their water
and the
the city even though it was so big and
so incredible suffered from incredible
political problems particularly around
infrastructure maintenance they had to
preserve all year round they had to have
water in giant reservoirs because they
had seasons of rain and seasons of
incredible dryness and so maintaining
reservoirs was really important for the
city and slowly over time as those
reservoirs decayed and the political
leaders didn't fix them the city became
less and less interesting for people to
live in shall we say and they started to
move away and so I've been thinking
about Angkor and the other cities that
I'm that I'm working on as kind of
models for the problems that we're
having in cities today and that brings
me to my final thing that I want to say
about world building and science fiction
and how it speaks to science because one
of the things that over the last decade
many of us working in science and
technology have had the luxury to forget
about is the fact that science is
political and science exists embedded in
political systems and you know for a
long time if you were working in basic
research in environmental science while
Obama was president
you got money from the government to do
your work on alternative energy and you
know it really felt like you know
there's supporters on both sides of the
aisle for technological innovation you
know people are investing in green
technology and other fields of science
who come from all political walks of
life but recently we've seen that that
has stopped being true in a lot of cases
and it has become a political issue it's
become a partisan issue and we're having
to remember that as scientists people
working on the scientific project that
we can't forget about politics we have
to think of our inventions and think of
our discoveries in that context whether
we like it or not and people working at
the intersection of culture and science
have known this for a long time
including Tom Lehrer this is one of my
favorite Tom Lehrer songs from the 1960s
tumblr was a physicist who also was a
great singer and he still teaches at
Santa Cruz and he has this famous song
called Verner von braun which is about a
physicist who helped develop atomic
weapons and didn't really care whom he
worked for do a little work for the
Germans do a little work for the
Americans whatever that's not his job he
called himself a political and I don't
think we can afford to do that anymore I
think that when we think about science
we need to remember that when we need to
draw a map around that that's science
and think about how it fits into all of
these different areas of non-scientific
life all these parts of society
especially if we want to get to a future
like what Star Trek promised us I'm
coming back to Star Trek and this is a
picture of Starfleet headquarters which
as you know is here in San Francisco
because we are the city of the future
and and you know if we take the
scientific project seriously what it's
about is learning as much as we can
about the truth of reality through
experimentation through reproducible
experimentation and then using that
knowledge of the truth to inform our
political decisions to inform our
economic decisions our infrastructure
decisions it's about having
evidence-based decision-making where
that evidence has been scientifically
looked at to scientifically examined and
the project of science fiction I think
is about making sure that as we're
thinking about that as we're thinking
about finding truth that we don't forget
about the fact that outside the lab
outside of the console where you're
doing development there's a whole map of
other kinds of influences and truths
there are social truths and cultural
truths that will affect how people
receive your technology how they deploy
it and what it does in the world and so
storytelling
is one of the best ways we have to think
about that map and to place our
discoveries in context so that we're not
surprised or blindsided when suddenly
this thing that we thought of as
completely apolitical
or completely peaceful in nature is
suddenly used in ways that we never
intended and it can also help us think
about whether we even want to develop a
technology in the first place do we
really want to invent slave sex robots I
don't know anyway so that's where I'll
leave you and if you need to reach me
I'm in some places I have a website I
have a new podcast called our opinions
are correct which I do with Charlie Jane
Anders over here but you're not going
away quite yet if you want to grab a yes
well thank you that was fantastic
[Applause]
so so we've got some time for questions
Joe's gonna be walking around with the
mic where you Joe extended up in the air
Joe's there in the back get to his
attention and he can get you the mic and
we can get your question into the mix I
have a couple yeah hi Emily
so I have questions so many questions
me too I'm ready yeah so let's let's
talk about forms that you did you did
some helpful as sort of talking about
fiction sci-fi let's talk about forms
so obviously the science fiction novel
is a is a a big form I mean what about
smaller sort of forms even of like at
the tweet level or what about you know
and and what is you know hard sci-fi
maybe we can go in a little bit more -
do you think that the hard sci-fi which
very you know has has very specific
science very much in there how do you
think about that compared to something
that maybe lighter on some of the
specifics but might actually ask very
profound questions how do you how do you
think about how both of those are or in
the Mac I think that you know we need a
big ecosystem of stories and and part of
the reason why I brought up Tom Lehrer
is not just because he's awesome which
obviously he is but is because he wrote
songs that were about kind of
contextualizing science within culture
most of them are very satirical not all
of his songs are about science but a lot
of them are and I think yeah tweets can
also fit into that I mean we can use I
mean in fact today to bring it up to the
president present not to the President
to bring it up to the present doing so
great tonight I know yeah we're really
avoiding quickly 6 but Janelle Monae has
a new album out called dirty computer
which is also very much about science
and technology in a social context and
it's just terrific and I think that to
the question about hard science fiction
I feel really ambivalent about that I
feel like there's science fiction as I
described it which is really just
fiction that's trying to think
speculatively about science to place it
in the middle of one of those worlds in
in a map
and you know sometimes because the
writer is someone like me I'm super
nerdy
I already write about science for a
living for me there's like nothing more
fun than having those limitations of
trying to make the science and
technology and my novel as realistic as
possible
so but that is a limitation that means
that there's certain things I can't do
I'm working on a novel right now which
is about time travel and I was like okay
I'm gonna make it scientific as possible
it's gonna be super awesome talk to a
physicist and he was like yeah no
actually that's not a thing you just
have to accept that it's a literary
device and then it's not ever gonna be
scientific so you just spoiled it for
all of us you realize I'm sorry yeah
you're never gonna travel through time
but my characters are traveling through
time there's a time machine up in Flin
Flon Manitoba so I think that you know
really the hard work that fiction does
whether it's fantasy or very nerdy
science fiction like mine is is
providing that story context and I mean
especially if you're doing science
fiction or fantasy that's very
psychological like philip k dick is a
great example like i said where you know
characters are like tripping out and
going crazy and their minds are like
dividing in half and stuff not very
scientifically realistic but it is it is
a way of reflecting how technology can
affect us psychologically so there's
depends on kind of what you're trying to
do and it was great to hear you talking
about the craft of it a bit it was great
to get into that on that front with with
the world-building I'm I'm curious I
mean there has to be even though it's
your novel and you get to decide
everything there are some things
probably on the cutting room floor that
you know art didn't actually is that
true there anything you didn't sort of
explicate and and is there anything like
a because I wonder about this with with
creators I guess in general of different
worlds if I ask you a question about how
XYZ works is it like that you go into
your head and look around and figure out
what it was and how that works or do you
have to like kind of think it out
imagine something to fill that space now
how would you extend your world or or
how do you how do you think about the
spaces that maybe haven't had a light
shined on them um I there's a lot of
stuff that is barely mentioned in the
novel that I thought about a lot like I
have a whole file that's just sort of
like backstory stuff that you know about
like the history but that's gone you
know it's 125 years in the future but I
filled in a whole timeline of like
political changes and like how robots
achieved the status of human equivalent
which would be released here about it
all in the book I've written a couple
short stories that are kind of set in
the time when robots and a eyes are
trying to assert human rights and would
you say they're in the same world yeah
they're in the same timeline yeah the
same world um and and so I kind of got
to do that in those short stories but
you know for me as I was saying like
when I started I kept looking at those
maps from the scientific article about
climate change so when I think about
like for example aspects of my world I
will if I'm dealing with something like
climate change I will go to the
scientific literature first and be like
okay what do people predict is likely to
happen given contemporary computer
modeling and the amount of data that we
have now and then that's when I get to
be creative so I know kind of what
scientific consensus is and then I have
characters who get to walk through that
world and get to live that world
in the same thing with artificial
intelligence like I was reading a lot of
articles by people who are working on AI
some of which I just have to be certain
that they aren't thinking about how will
be perceived um later people talking
about trying to make happy slaves for
example which is not a thing like if you
create a human equivalent being like
there's no such thing as a thinking
being that's a happy slave like that's
just not something that you can do you
can't make them both human equivalent
and a happy slave so so that's why
that's where the kind of creativity and
weirdness comes in is like okay I
invented a sexy robot you know with
awesome lasers like just what I always
wanted
one more for me and then we'll we'll get
questions from the audience so you know
science is a group activity ultimately
with scientists all kind of taking
different pieces of what's going on how
do you think about other science fiction
writers I mean when you're like going to
take on a subject like time travel are
you kind of doing a survey I mean
obviously you would have read other time
thing but how do you think about the
other sort of ideation the other
iterations people have done through a
concept like that or even through a very
specific thing how do you how do you
think about that body of work and then
yeah I am one of those writers who loves
to read a ton of stuff in the actual
sub-genre that I'm working in I know
other writers who say like when they're
working on a topic they're just like I
don't read anything similar to it at all
I don't want to like be polluted but
when I was working on autonomous I
certainly was reading a ton of stuff
about well scientific papers but also
ton of science fiction about you know AI
and about and looking at how people were
representing robots and and then up into
the present like I'm still doing that
all the time
and same thing with time travel like I
definitely thought like okay do I want
my time travel to be more like back to
the future or more like primer or more
like looper or like you know or more
like the time machine and the answer is
actually it's not really like anything
but I did think about them and it is
definitely like I mean it's closest to
being back to the future but like I
thought about it you know I was like
okay it kind of fits in here and like I
just I consider that to be the kind of
cultural context for what I'm writing in
and not that you need to have read a ton
of science fiction to enjoy it but I
think for me it's it's my Canon you know
i that's how i learn how to write as by
reading so um yeah we got a question
back there I'll make sure to hold it
really close to your mouth closer than
you think you need to you hear me now
yes thank you a little bit from your
in your discussion in general but I'm
curious how you hope we might navigate
the difficult transition that you're
talking about us moving fruit where
we're creating these tools that become
self-aware enough that we need to allow
them a certain amount of autonomy or
have concerns about their suffering I
think you you've pointed to the
historical and currents of slavery as
well as well the best case scenario I
don't think we're gonna unfortunately
have the best case scenario I really do
think that if we do yeah I mean well as
I said I really think about kind of the
space in between utopia and dystopia
where it's kind of a little bit of bad a
little bit of good I'm sure that it's
gonna vary a lot from country to country
for example and I think I mean for me
like a best-case scenario would be if we
ever are approaching having human
equivalent intelligence which is a big
if we don't really know if we're gonna
get there I know Google thinks that we
are and yay for them I hope they're
thinking about all this stuff I I mean I
would hope that we would be doing some
equivalent of trying to check in and
communicate with what we're making and
asking like how you doing but that's a
tall order because we don't know exactly
what AI will be like when it emerges I
tend to think that it might be something
like an extremely non neurotypical mind
so we might not recognize communication
it might be trying to tell us stuff and
we won't necessarily know because it's
not using the kind of communication that
we are used to I think about this a lot
with animals like dolphins where there's
clearly an intelligence there we know
that they have names for each other we
know that they communicate using
verbalizations vocalizations as
scientists say they don't want to call
it a language but it is and and one of
the problems that scientists have had is
that we can't get dolphins to learn
English you know like so they and so
then you know there's this idea like
well they're not really smart because
they're not like dogs who understand
when we say fetch because they only
speak like dolphin you know and and so
us having to learn dolphin is considered
me it's somehow we we revalue that is
like well that must mean that the
dolphins are stupid because they can't
learn English instead of maybe
considering the possibility that we're
stupid because we haven't learned come
on English we love English the world's
language yay colonization um so yeah we
we conquered the world with English um
so I think that I mean what I would hope
is that what we're learning in the
process of doing things like trying to
communicate with really radically
different consciousness in animals might
aid us but I do think we're gonna have
pretty rough time for a while I think
there's gonna be a lot of abuse question
there then thank you for tonight's talk
I'm very curious about this distinction
of utopian and dystopian it's something
that that comes up here at long now
quite a bit and yeah there's definitely
been the pendulum seems to swing the
utopian space to the dystopian space and
we seem to be you know in about 40 years
ago we were very much in the maybe 50
and 60 years ago we were going through a
very utopian space and now we're going
through much more dystopian space and I
noticed that the science fiction of the
utopian space seems to think and project
much further into the future and then
the science fiction of the dystopian
space seems to become very present issed
mmm-hmm and so you mentioned that
science fiction is now present it's but
I wondered you know if you were truly a
utopian one would you be thinking
further or not
do you think that matters or or not so I
mean as I was sort of gesturing at in my
talk I'm really trying to do something
that's taupe Ian you know that's not
either that's neither dystopian nor
utopia because I think that's as
realistic as we can get in our
storytelling a lot of the narratives
that we think of from the 60s is
classical utopian like Star Trek if you
actually are a person like me who's
watched as much Star Trek as there is
available you will know that there are
many parts of the Star Trek universe
that are deeply what we would call
dystopian Deep Space 9 is about that
it's about post-colonial relationships
on a world that's been horrifically
brutalized by an imperial force the new
series discovery which you know say what
you will it's a bit uneven but it has an
incredible approach to thinking about
science in the context of a world that
has become devoted to war and the ship
that's a science ship is turned into a
warship this incredible science
experiment with the mycelial Network
which is kind of badass I mean it's like
space mushroom Network which is what
they use to kind of teleport through
time or teleport through space and time
anyway it becomes weaponized and so it
becomes a fantastic thought experiment
about a very dark turn cultural turn
where a seemingly apolitical scientific
project is politicized and weaponized
and so I think if you dig a little bit
under the surface of almost any story
that you think of as utopian or
dystopian you find that there's actually
a lot more going on and and it's the
same thing like William Gibson is always
being accused of being dystopian I know
he doesn't think he is dystopian he
thinks he's just realistic I mean he
often has quite delightful characters
who have kind hearts and and try to make
the world better that you know are
really genuinely likable people which
you don't always see in science fiction
so I mean that's one of the things I
love about Gibson's work so so I try to
always be mindful of staying in that
space between and I
now in the United States feels very
dystopian because there's a lot of
political and economic developments that
are objectively bad in I mean for
everyone and so I mean the nation is
having troubles where worse where
there's political strife and that's
always bad I don't mean like I'm not
trying to say like the president is evil
I'm just saying that times of political
instability are bad and history kind of
bears me out on that so so we feel
dystopian because we're in a world where
we feel very uncertain about the future
but I think that our storytelling
continues to be the best storytelling
continues to be pretty nuanced so I hope
hashtag weaponized shrooms y'all and
actually on the the toe peon front I
having Kelly are along a board member
I've recently heard him use the term
proto peon meaning it's like at least 1%
over of more utopia it's like more
better it's like he wants a net net
opium net utopian but it's not all total
but but it ends up on the positive side
when we talk about fiction as part of
the scientific enterprise what does that
mean as far as the attention that needs
to be coming from the more formal
scientific apparatus I mean and are you
kind of do you think that's happening
right now I mean I I think about and
it's you know we have the the internet
serves as this amazing kind of
omnipresent cultural blender that's
ready to pick up whether its facts or
fiction yeah spin it around and iterate
on it and we've had you know during your
talk I thought of a couple we've had
Miles Trevor who's spoken for us who's a
geologist and he's looked at Game of
Thrones and reverse-engineered what the
geology of that planet needs to be if
you look up the geology of Game of
Thrones you can find it's an amazing
website yeah I've talked to him
it's yeah he used actually a tool that
geologists used to map terrain and and
kind of talk about plate tectonics and
and projected onto gameofthrones so
that's a great example yeah and he
already assumes it must be internally
consistent so I can apply my scientific
tools to it he also does the carbon
footprint of super-heroes which is a lot
of fun that's yeah that's interesting
yeah and then and then on the flip side
we've had daniel suarez book for us a
long time ago and Dan's first book
Damon was about basically technologies
that he saw around and he realized I
could either write a white paper about
these or I could write a thriller about
that I bet more people would pay
attention if I wrote a thriller and and
it talked about how network technologies
had some some vulnerabilities
interesting things so do you think
there's the right level of kind of
conversation or or attention being paid
to and certainly as we've had SAN from
Stanley Robinson speak here that's what
he wants he is trying to be part of a
dialogue what are your thoughts on that
can it improve and what would you I
definitely think I mean there's always
room for improvement I think you know it
really depends on the scientist and the
project that they're working on I think
some scientists are super open to
thinking about their work in the context
of culture and storytelling and others
prefer to be apolitical
and that's you know changing I think
we're there being a political okay you
know and but I think one of the things
that's been very positive I feel in the
past couple years as I've seen things
like I projected a picture up there from
the science March which was a bunch of
marches organized in different cities
people just saying like yeah I'm Pro
science like I don't have a political
agenda per se but I guess you've made
science into a political agenda a lot of
scientists are going into politics now
there's been a really strong move among
scientists locally actually Mike Eisen
who teaches biology over at Berkeley I
was running for Senate which is kind of
weird but kind of awesome and and lots
of other people are running in more
local races as well people who've worked
in environmental science for example
which we could really use more
environmental scientists and engineers
and urban
I think in politics and like I said for
a long time I think we sort of felt like
well the scientific project doesn't need
to touch politics doesn't need to touch
this map of the world that goes beyond
the laboratory and I think people
scientists now are more open to that
idea and realized that you know if they
want evidence from science to affect
public policy and to affect things like
you know resource allocation and
infrastructure development that they're
actually gonna have to go out there into
that world beyond the ivory tower beyond
their corporate labs and do something
and I think that isn't the same thing as
saying like you should read more science
fiction but it's the same impulse to to
do something that is cultural or
political or speculative or social that
can't necessarily be quantified by
repeatable testing but will nevertheless
have a measurable effect on the world
another question there we go thank you I
just wanted to just throw out you know
to think more deeply on that the whole
idea of if we can imagine if and it must
be possible going all the way back to
ideal and that kind of stuff so what are
your thoughts on that just generally and
I feel very strongly that if we can't
imagine it that somehow just us humans
because we're tubers that we will make
it happen
yeah no definitely and I don't I didn't
mean to say that imagination and
speculation aren't involved in
scientific discovery or technical
innovation I mean obviously they are
what I meant when I said science fiction
isn't predictive is just that well like
I said no one can really predict the
future what we can do is we can look at
the science and technology around us now
and think about a another thing
speculatively about where they might fit
into say a future civilization
one of the things the reason I projected
that picture up of Spock with the
tricorder is because so we always think
of the tricorder and the communicator as
things that inspired mobile devices and
it's true
does the early designs for mobile
devices were directly inspired by the
early the original series communicators
not the little pins that they have in
next generation that's what I want like
captain I have a science fiction novel
for you so what what Star Trek did that
was so genius it with the tricorder
thinking about how it would be embedded
in culture is that you may recall that
there isn't just one kind of tricorder
like everybody has the little purse with
the tricorder and they bring it down to
the planet and they're like boop boop
boop
oh I've noticed the molecules are doing
this however there's also a medical
tricorder which has the little doohickey
that comes off of it and I guess I don't
know it can do special biological
measurements or things that are more
localized and that is a great example of
thinking about how technology is really
used because a lot of lazy science
fiction would be like tricorder
everybody has one they do everything but
in Star Trek they were like no
technology develops for special use
cases or for special applications and so
you're not just gonna have like a
tricorder you're gonna have different
kinds and we assume that there's
probably other kinds out there too we
just don't see them cuz we're on a
spaceship and so we're not like
veterinarians or whatever you know
there's like a veterinarian tricorder
and there's like a an opera singer
tricorder for like checking your throat
muscles or whatever right and so I think
that's what science fiction can do so
like I said it's not a prediction but
it's a way of getting people to think
about as you're developing technology
remember it's not a one-size-fits-all
thing right your tech is going to be
taken up and received in different ways
by different communities so I think
that's the importance of how science
fiction works I think of it as the
difference between like a prediction
like a time prediction versus looking at
things in space I really think in terms
of maps and spaces and like that's how I
sort of imagine technology in science
fiction it's in a map of a spate of a
social space or a political space and we
kind of look at how
kind of gets used in that map and it
could be a literal map like how our
mobile devices used say in African
nations versus European nations and we
can think about that in the present and
then maybe project into a future where
there's even more radically different
uses of mobile devices in nations on
those two continents sort of how
politically powerful sort of changes of
framings and sort of rhetorical phrases
can be I'm curious if there's any others
that you wish that people would use more
of or that you've seen recently that
you're like oh I wish that people would
just use this phrase actually there is
funny it had funny that uses a planted
question yeah I've been thinking a lot
because I'm working on this book about
archaeology and about ancient
civilizations and when I I've been
writing about Cahokia which is a city
that was built by Native Americans about
a thousand years ago outside st. Louis
in fact most of the city is under East
st. Louis it was this incredible city
with like pyramids and you know tons of
people were living there was an enormous
City biggest city in North America until
Europeans arrived and the way that the
city was run isn't you know
archaeologists don't think it was like
what we think of as as a city like there
was no central authority really I mean
there was some dude who stood on top of
the mound and like maybe yelled at
people but there wasn't like a king or
like a prince or a princess or whatever
and the term that they use to describe
it is a header Archy so instead of like
a monarchy you have a header Archy where
there's multiple sources of power in the
community and in in a lot of different
Native American groups at that time
there were these this idea and actually
this is true in early European
communities as well instead of having
like a central leader you'd have like
the people who deal
with pottery the people who deal with
farming the people who deal with ritual
the people who deal with cooking
well maybe cooking would be house by
house but like different areas that
serve the community would have their own
kind of group like a guild basically but
a guild where there's no King and so it
was when I when her Keala gist first
started using that term it was really
hard for me I was like what the [ __ ]
where's a header our key but it's it's
plural power and it's such a great idea
and I think there's a lot of groups that
we are all participating in I think here
in San Francisco perhaps that have a bit
of a header ARCIC structure so yeah
that's my that's my word of the day well
I love you actually ended that in the
perfect place for me last the last
question I want to ask you and then we
go shoot she's gonna stick around we'd
love to have you stick around get your
book signed more books for sale on the
back and and that you're gonna keep
answering questions the whole time I
will yeah so you know the you you
mentioned Gibson earlier it kind of
blows my mind be his his quote that the
futures already here it's just not
evenly distributed it feels just more
real every second but the thing I've
been thinking about more and more is
that there are places where the future
bogs down and and where there's more
future than than less in San Francisco
and the Bay Area is definitely one of
those places that has it seems like a
lot of the future as somebody who's been
here and you know it's it's great to
have a science fiction writer who is a
San Franciscan because you know it's
it's not so easy for anybody be a San
Franciscan these days and having having
been here as long as you have having
seen all these changes and there's and
there's a real in a way you know you
could almost say San Francisco's that is
the fiction for Silicon Valley's
technology if not science all the time
yeah and in a lot of ways yeah what what
are your thoughts about the future the
perspective on the future
from this vantage point and where that's
good and maybe where that's not always
so good um so it's interesting because I
love William Gibson and I think that
that quote is very catchy but I actually
disagree I think that the future comes
to everywhere I think we're all existing
in exactly the same time and that what
is unevenly distributed of course is
wealth not the future you know Africa is
gonna be in the same future we are it's
a whole continent of future and that was
actually one of the reasons why I loved
the kind of you know in in black panther
which is really just about a guy in a
suit you know fighting bad guys but we
get this view how many people saw black
panther okay good job so black panther
is from a hidden nation in Africa called
Wakanda which is highly it's very very
wealthy they are technologically
advanced because they are wealthy and
they are wealthy because they've
exploited a resource they have access to
called vibranium which is what Captain
America's shield is made out of for
those of you who are familiar with
Captain America and it's just a super
strong metal it has all these other
properties to it can do like all kinds
of stuff and it's valuable and they sell
it for money so that they can have an
incredibly advanced technology and
wealthy nation and that feels very
futuristic but doesn't look like the
vision of the future that we have here
in San Francisco which is like more like
an Apple store vision of the future and
and actually is literally white and and
that was one of the things that a lot of
us watching Black Panther thought was so
amazing was that it was a vision of the
future that felt African and it's very
pan-african and actually people from
Africa were like what like what is this
because it like mixes up a bunch of
different tribal traditions it's like I
don't know it's like pan-asian food or
something it's pan-african futurism so I
think that it's important to remember
when we talk about the future what
exactly we mean
I think when you say like we have a lot
of future piled up here in San Francisco
what we really mean is we have a lot of
money here we have a lot of rich people
here we have a lot of investment here
and I'm not saying that's bad I mean
it's resulted in a lot of really cool
things that I love and use every day
like my phone and my internet and my
Google and which is of course mine all
mine and you know but I mean I I reap
the benefits of it so I think that you
know the perspective that we get in San
Francisco is the perspective of wealth
and that gives us just as narrow a
perspective as you would get living in
Saskatchewan where my characters are
from in my novel you know growing up on
a farm in rural Saskatchewan you know it
seems like from our perspective would
give you this very limited view of the
world but how many of you know what it's
like to grow up on a farm in
Saskatchewan probably not that many
except for Jesse right here and who
didn't even really grow up on a farm so
you don't even know so I think that it's
you know no matter where you are you
know you you have to remember that
there's always other perspectives and so
that's like the whole point that I'm
trying to make is that the future looks
different depending on where you're
standing and you know we think it looks
like money other places might think the
future looks like something else it's
important when you're a man this is like
to tie it back to why science needs
fiction and stories and you know
personal stories for example is that
when you're designing technology
oftentimes the temptation is to design
it for that white Apple store right like
all the white people in the white Apple
store but those are not your users
that's not the world that's not who
Altima will receive that technology or
that science and so the more that we can
have stories science fiction stories or
otherwise that place technology in
different contexts like Wakanda
for example the more we actually have a
really robust and and diverse ecosystem
of science
attack and I think that's what's gonna
make the future you know be a more
hospitable place for the maximum number
of intelligent beings so Annalee Nuits
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]